but we use this occasion with the last
ever game to be played at the oakland
coliseum to do a draft of
the baddest raiders of all time i don't
know whether we approved ultimately the
most badass raiders or the baddest
raiders either way that's the spirit of
it it can be raiders from any era at any
time that's the draft chris you've got
the trivia question to determine the
first choice go all right well as you
know they're playing their final home
game in oakland against the jaguars in
the history of the raiders this is
amazing actually in the history of the
raiders only one player has made 10 or
more pro bowls who is that player
art shell ah good guess but no it will
be a gym otto
gym auto oh double zero gym auto
uh i know it was somebody on that
offensive line yeah it was either upshaw
art shell or gym auto yeah did you get
the first pick that's all right that was
a tough one that really was it actually
is surprising with such a great
franchise that that's the only one i
would have thought maybe there'd been
you know one or two others but um all
right well i mean
i i don't know i gotta start here when
you're talking about badass raiders i
mean i'm going with al davis to start it
off i mean he's the one that started the
badass raiders i mean he is the guy he's
the guy that used to walk around in a
white leather jumpsuit with a with a
raiders emblem on it encrusted in
diamonds i mean come on if that doesn't
look like a badass right there with a
pinky ring bling bling i mean he fought
against the nfl he instilled the
attitude of the raiders into that
organization that all came from him a
brooklyn guy a tough in your face like
if you don't like it fu just win baby
the reason the super bowl rings are the
way they are today is because of al
davis you were only allowed to spend a
certain amount of money on the rings so
he maximized that and then he told the
company charge me ten thousand dollars
for the box of each ring and that's why
they are the way they are too which is
amazing so
al davis is the leader of the badasses
when it comes to the raiders
yeah i mean look there's only one guy in
the franchise they light a flame for
before every game and it's al davis so i
agree with you that would have been my
pick too thanks for the difficult trivia
question back there
i would have had the i take back my
compliment from earlier in the program
about the split screen with me and chris
and and peter king all right uh but and
there are so many different ways you can
go with this now but i got to go with
ken stabler when i think raiders i think
ken stabler a guy who was denied
admission to the hall of fame
unjustifiably for years a guy who led
the team to its first ever super bowl
win a lefty a guy who just in the 70s
and and that was the era where i first
discovered football the raiders were
always good the raiders were always
competitive that sea of hands throw that
ended the dolphins dynasty at the end of
the game the catch by clarence davis in
the end zone incredible plays by ken
stabler when when i thought raiders i
thought ken stable i mean i thought he
was the guy with the eye patch on on the
side of the helmet that's the raiders to
me and uh he's always one of the first
guys i think of when i think the oakland
raiders yeah i get it i think that would
have been my next pick too or if it
would have been my first pick if you got
al davis yes i mean come on he's a lefty
quarterback one
he was a badass i mean you know just
seemed like the type that be he might
have drank a beer and smoked a cigarette
at halftime in a game and been like hey
screw you i'm still gonna go out there
and throw three touchdown passes quick
story we're playing the raiders in 2004
they're talking about me maybe becoming
the starter and replacing brad johnson
right we go out there to play a game i
wear a throwback ken stabler jersey to
the game right and because i'm like i'm
going to pay tribute to a lefty here i'm
going to wear the white
ken stabler jersey and i'm thinking i'm
cool and i got guys in the locker room
like man that's a great jersey all of a
sudden john gruden and one of his
assistants comes up to me and they were
livid that i were why would you wear
that jersey i can't believe you wore
that al davis is gonna love that you
wore that jersey and i was like uh oh
okay i don't know what to say i i mean i
wore the jersey to pay respect to the
guy but uh they were they were pissed
off that i wore that jersey that day did
you hear from al davis about it no i
never did no but uh i got a little spent
a little time with al davis before it
was a very this very special time to be
talking football and i'm almost like
talking to a bill belichick where you're
just like wow this is amazing did he
call you phil
no he did not most people do but he did
not uh all right all right i'm stuck
here there's so many good guys to pick
from but i'm gonna go with one from my
childhood uh that i really think of when
i think of the razors and that's lester
hayes lester the molester hayes okay
because i just think he exudes raiders
like in your face corner back remember
he used to have his fingers tight taped
up and he'd have him between his legs
and wiggle in his fingers like come on
bring it and then he'd have like to
stick him all over his hands and arms so
when he did jam the receiver they almost
like stuck to him that way but i i got
to go with him because i just remember
watching my dad play him and you know
1986 and other year during that time
frame when i was very young and just
going who is this guy wearing 37. he's
so cool and just in your face and of
course he was one of the best corners in
football and uh kind of just
he he meant raiders to me and one of
their one of their all-time interception
leaders for the oakland raiders as well
yeah and and i remember those days where
they had that stick them just gooped all
over them on their helmets on their shoe
on their socks everywhere just just
dripping there are some photos out there
and you can just see it just dripping
off of lester hayes hands but he was
that first
the the first
cornerback the first modern cornerback
for me that really resonated is a guy
that just was a shutdown guy they still
kept throwing it his way and he still
kept picking it off
i'm gonna stay and this really gets
difficult there are so many bad ass
raiders over the years that's amazing
and this and and this guy was a super
bowl mvp even though ken stabler led
them to their first super bowl win
against the minnesota vikings and i
remember watching that fame game very
closely and not being very happy with
the raiders when it ended but fred
belitnikov was incredible wearing that
floppy helmet with the the the two bar
face mask and just get and back in those
days you paid for it every time you
caught a pass you paid for it he
probably paid for it in practice against
the likes of jack tatum and company
right he definitely paid for it during
games but fred belitnikov was was one a
one-of-a-kind hall of famer they named
the college football award after him for
the best receiver every year uh
baletnikov was one of a kind and again i
feel i feel like i'm gonna we we need to
do five rounds
to get to all the guys who deserve it
who do you got next yeah well i know i i
do i feel bad you're right i'm going to
go with hallie long but i really want to
pick kind of jack tatum too but it's the
last one and i'm going to go i already
picked the db so i'm trying to change
the wealth here i'm going to go with
hallie long because like howie long is i
mean of course a hall of fame defensive
lineman you know he kind of like exudes
like toughness in your face in a silent
type of way maybe not as brash as you
know some of the other personalities we
talked about but also he's an oakland
raider to me from the standpoint of like
okay uh you want to step outside when
we're in the bar and howie long will
like you know knock you out and like
seven other people all at the same time
i mean his head is the size of a cinder
block okay so he's intimidating that way
but then
also very california oakland raiderish
that where yeah he could beat you up in
a bar fight but at the same time after
that fight's over go to a gq cover shoot
and be like gq man of the year in
hollywood and so handsome and like
perfect that way too and to me that's
part of the raiders as well their
showmanships their their hollywoodness
of that franchise to where uh howie
long's still doing great things on fox
and tv and everything like that i got a
lot of respect for him
my mother
my mother has a crush on a
gigantic crush on howie long back when
he was playing same with my aunt wendy
you know my aunt wendy
she loved hallie long yep
yep so uh and he's right he didn't he
didn't you know he wasn't the guy that
would take your helmet off and hit you
over the head with at least not when
anyone was looking right and uh he had a
different image than the other
raider renegades like the bill
romanowskis the lyle alzados
but still he was he was a badass in his
own way yeah i do have to go jack tatum
yeah and look what happened with daryl
stingley was uh unfortunate um it's
something that you'd get ejected from
the league forever for if you even came
close to it nowadays i don't know how
jack tatum would have survived in
today's nfl but in the 70s that's the
way it was and the nfl marketed it i
mean they eventually would make the
videos with all the big hits and jack
tatum had a ton of them he was an
intimidator his book was they call me
assassin and uh he lived up to it every
time he was on the field
think about that if you that's the sami
white hit from super bowl 11 that
knocked his helmet off we thought that
was kind of quaint and neat at the time
that's just football if you would do
that now
you would be
removed by security you would be
suspended and all rightfully so but it
just shows you how the game has changed
how brutal it was back then and jack
tatum was the guy who who was identified
with that brand of football yeah
definitely i mean you want to talk about
a receiver and you better have your head
on a swivel holy cow i mean there's no
wonder the guy only played nine years in
the nfl i mean not only did he knock
other people out his body couldn't take
any more of those car crash collisions
but yeah he's certainly one of the guys
that deserves to be on this list
all right you got any more is that it
that's it you got one more throw one
more in well i mean li you said lyle i
mean there's so many like because like
tim brown is awesome right and but i
don't know if i'm going to put him in
the badass category
so i guess i kind of go lyle alzado next
he's the next guy that'll jump out to me
that way uh you know just
just again in your face unbelievable
personality will beat you up in tents
gotta you know
talking crap on the sidelines yeah i
mean we know he experimented with some
drugs at the time to make himself even
more of a badass and but i don't know
holy cow he just threw that guy's helmet
at him i mean that's unbelievable that's
a raider that's a badass thank you for
supporting me with that video evidence
uh back in the control room i appreciate
that
and you know he didn't play for the
raiders for very long he had most of his
career with the broncos but we only
think of him as a raider yeah i mean it
was like he was destined to be a raider
oh god he yeah football was different
football was very different back in the
a 80s raider last one for me is ted ted
hendricks the mad stork yeah i remember
the first time i heard that nickname the
mad stork i thought that is awesome and
ted hendricks was awesome he played uh
with the team for nearly a decade he was
with the colts for a while the packers
fear but kind of like lyle alzado when
he finally landed where he was supposed
to be all along it just it just worked
and uh ted hendricks my last pick we had
to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports